three High Street shampoos that you need
to avoid like the plague number one head
and shoulders there are much better
shampoos that you can use for dandruff
that you can get from your local
pharmacy Head and Shoulders contain
sulfates which can dry out the scalp and
over time leave your hair looking dull
and dry also Head and Shoulders can lead
to color fade outs if you spent dollar
dollar dollar on having amazing dyed
hair this may fade it a lot quicker than
you want it to go number two t now these
products contain sulfates again to dry
out the hair but also contain silicones
which can build upon the scalp and cause
itchiness and irritation of the scalp so
I would recommend not to use Tres number
three OGX now this brand which is quite
popular and is available in most
drugstores has actually got an alleged
lawsuit against it now I'm not sure of
the ins and outs but I think it's
because of hair loss or hair thinning
now they do contain chemicals which can
be quite strong on the scalp and can
lead to irritation they do claim to be
sulfate free however but again I would
just avoid